seit dem filmklassiker back to the
future 2 aus dem jahre 1989 sind alle
verrückt nach dem hammer wort im film
heißt martin klein das jahr 2015 und
fährt dort unter anderem auf einem hof
bord je näher wir dem 21 oktober kommen
das ist der tag an dem martin im jahr
2015 an kommen desto mehr scheinen auf
den markt zu kommen aber ist das alles
mehr fiction als 1 oder könnte es ein
echtes hammer bord wirklich geben die
antwort gibt es jetzt bei water
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
watsons das cover bord ist seit über 25
jahren der traum von so ziemlich jedem
jungen und sogar der ursprung vieler
skater karrieren und genau diese
sehnsucht machten sich die jungs von
funnyordie 2014 zu nutze in einem
gefakten werbeclip für das rupert
eckkrammer wort vorgestellt dabei sind
unter anderem einer der schauspieler von
back to the future und skate legende
tony hawkins das video wurde allerdings
schnell als fake enttarnt in wahrheit
wurden die schauspieler auf einen kran
durch die luft gezogen viele back to the
future fans blieben enttäuscht zurück
doch das feedback auf das video damals
hat gezeigt sehr sehr viele menschen
sind einer motherboard wirklich
interessiert potenzial für eine menge
kunden doch dieser mann konnte nicht zu
lange warten und hat sich kurzerhand
sein eigenes wort gebaut es basiert zwar
nicht auf magneten und steht geräuschlos
über den boden aber es funktioniert mit
hilfe von acht propellern stellte der
kanadier den weltrekord im hammerwurf
weitflug auf ich wusste gar nicht dass
es das gibt 275 meter weit flog der mann
über wasser und steuerte seinen hammer
boards dabei mit den eigenen füßen laut
eigenen angaben ist das das weltweit
erste echte und funktionierende haver
bord doch wirklich praktisch ist das
ding natürlich nicht neben der hohen
lautstärke und dem sperrigen format kann
es im moment auch noch nicht besonders
weit fliegen und ich glaube es geht
tricks und damit auch noch nicht so
wirklich möglich näher an diese vision
kommt damit schon handy die firma hat
auch geeks daten über eine halbe million
us dollar für die entwicklung eines
echten hammer boards bekommen ein
prototyp existiert bereits und auch
dieser wurde von tony hat getestet wie
ihr seht steht das ging leider nur über
einen boden aus kupfer ist auch relativ
sperrig lässt sich noch nicht wirklich
mit den füßen kontrollieren und was sie
leider nicht hören könnt es ist verdammt
laut der magnet mechanismus der das
board schweben lässt macht nämlich eine
menge kraft wenn ihr also einen kupfer
boden zu hause habt dann könnt ihr das
ding in ein paar jahren für läppische
10.000 dollar kaufen nichts was sich
normalsterbliche wirklich auch spaß
leisten können aber das cover bord ist
für händler sowieso nur ein nebenprojekt
die technologie soll in zukunft ganze
gebäude aus der gefahrenzone von
naturgewalten schweben lassen das sind
große pläne die man leben retten könnten
aber das hobart lasst uns back to the
future versprochen hat ist das immer
noch nicht zur rettung alt lexus viele
von euch haben vielleicht mitbekommen
vor wenigen wochen hat lexus ein eigenes
cover bord angeteasert nach dem
geschenkten videoclub von funnyordie
haben natürlich die allermeisten von
euch sofort den startknopf gedrückt und
behauptet dass das alles nur eine große
werbekampagne ist und naja das ist es
leid wie lexus is nennt ist teil
mehrerer projekte wie wahrscheinlich das
design eines neuen autos anti sein
sollen und nein auch das schwebt
natürlich nicht aber auch wenn lexus
unsere hoffnungen und träume eiskalt
ausnutzt um werbung zu machen heißt das
nicht dass das cover bord von lexus
nicht echt sein kann auf ihrer website
schreiben sie dass das abort mit hilfe
von supraleitern und magneten die
quanten levitation erreicht ein
supraleiter das material hat keinen
elektrischen widerstand und muss dafür
sehr stark abgekühlt werden lexus
behauptet dass sie die benötigten
niedrigen temperaturen mit hilfe von
flüssigem stickstoff erreichen können
das würde auch den effektvollen nebel
erklären an und für sich funktioniert
diese technik sehr gut wie man in diesen
genialen video sehen kann lexus ansatz
ist zwar leiser als die technik die
hände verwendet dafür muss das material
aber immer wieder gekühlt werden
vermutlich verschwindet der supraleitung
effekt schon nach wenigen minuten danach
muss wieder nachgefüllt werden aber auf
einen magnetischen boden kann auch lexus
an bord nicht verzichten zur arbeit oder
zur schule schweben kann man auch hier
mit total vergessen solange eure stadt
nicht jeden einzelnen bürger steigt in
der ganzen stadt umbauen lässt im teaser
von lexus is allerdings beton zu sehen
irre führen aber wie so oft kommt das
internet zu hilfe anscheinend hat jemand
entdeckt dass lexus in spanien an einem
echten skaterpark arbeitet und noch viel
wichtiger unter der unfertigen
oberfläche kann man klar und deutlich
erkennen dass an einem metall boden
gearbeitet wird lexus wollte natürlich
nicht dass jemand den skaterpark
außerhalb von barcelona sieht wofür er
fertig ist und es ist auch noch nicht
klar ob dieser parcours gebaut wird um
coole videos zu drehen oder ob auch
normale menschen zugang bekommen werden
so oder so ist das alles verdammt
spannend und aufregend und ich würde
wetten dass wir alle allerspätestens am
21 oktober 2015 mehr über das rabatt von
lexus erfahren werden
was man hier ist lexus hat echt oder ist
das alles nur ein genialer
marketingtrick schreibt sie auf jeden
fall unten in die kommentare schon sehr
gespannt was ihr dazu zu sagen gehabt
wenn ihr mehr von watts ansehen wollt
findet ihr rechts die beiden letzten
videos der schnellste zug der welt der
heimflug von tesla und virtual reality
das ganze findet ihr unten viel spaß und
bis zum nächsten mal